T
FOLKS.
>> ALL THE ANG THEER
OMHE W,
NDVANDER O M'S THE LATESHIRUSS U
JU BTTACKS CITTHDE
OS
NOW, THOSE MULPL
IX TT TO SCENEE SHORTLY AFTER, W
F SMOKRIA
GEACIPLE LOCATIONS.
E MOST
N THIS CITY E RUSSIAN  ACANT
THER THAT IG HAPPENED IT IS MOSY
SEE SHATTERED GLASS FROM ACRS ER
FADING. THATAD
SEVERAW AD
HEARD AND  DRO
DRONESIN
FUED  ALL LEADING UTHIS MORNIN
IMPAC MINUTES A
THE THAT FUEL STORAGE OFFICIS E,
IC INJS  E WE CS
IN
DESPATRKING TO PUT
THRE
OSHOULDERHE M
RARAGE
FACILI.
BORI
YR TAHERE.
THANK YOU FOR THREPO> NOW TO LV
BLK.PHIL, RUSSGRARE
S VE OS OU T THE
SOW IN THO I A
MOMENT
HAVE B RUSSIRIDEE RCES
ATAKTHE L.
T FAILED, THEIR ATTS
TOIRTHRE
SEEING OUT OF THIS NEWLY RELAM
CLTERRITORY, SHOWS E EXNSMAGE
AND RUSSIASOLDIERS.
CE O
OCKE USISTANCE AND WHA WAS
TORY.
BODIES AT LE A
A R IMPLICATION, THESE ERE A RE
S BEENN FORCES
L OF NBASITY WHAT'S TO COMEE EFA
IT'S EEC
STE S THAT Y IT WILL ESTABLH
DISLODGE PTIWITH TUIPPED AS IT
IS. OFFICER
SOMETHG TO SHOW THTIHAS SEOF A V
MORE RON AMENT THEE 9th KNOWN AY
U.CK A BROADER SENSE.>> PHIL BK
ITINWIINGTON, DELAWARE.OD MORNI.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS  CRE
>> Reporter: THAT'GHT.
IT'S L AND NATE
TRMORE W
SOMETHING UKRAINE PRESIDENT D NT
TO T ERA TANKS FROMALLIED NATIH
REGION WE JUTO
TALK AES THFI IN THIS
CTS THE S.D
FACILITATE TRANSFER OF TANKS
NOW WE KTHAT, OR RAT
DON KNOW ISW MANY
TANKS TH WE ANSFER WHEN TH
HAPPENS, A SOURCN IT
WOULD N DAYS AND EKS NEWS COMESR
NT
D  300 MILLION IN
SECURITYO D THAT GUONESEN
THINGS
BOTER UKRAINE ONBATTLEFIELS  SET
SOMETHING THAT HAS LUDN  T TER .
BEEADMENT ABOUT HAVING
BUU.S. SAI
PRAIC
THOUGH ONE THI THAT'S
LAS CONTINUE
IN CONSTI WITH  ASSESS ATATTRYA
LTIME.
NE WRIGHTRTHE WILMINGTON, LAWARR
U.E INDICATEORIRED GENER.ANK YOH
D ON THE
EASTPAIN
THE DONBASRAIAE REREN
RUSSIA OR A FT IN ENFO
W TS ESSMENESULTINGN
TERTO IINE
EVER THEY CAN.
W, RUSSIANS WI
AS MUCH  NSO THEY HAVE EEDO ABAO
FOR , AT LEAST
TIMO PS INTE EAST WHERERUGGLIBI
SURE TT
ESSFUL IN CREATINGHI
NG THE COAST O
BL I THINK WE ISEEA, A REAL ATE
ONS YLOR, PEAPPEAR AS  G
NG AT THE ULIES ARE
GUARANTEINIAY IF IS INTO CONCESH
AGGRESSIONTHFU,
>>ORIA
UNND, AND I THINK THE
WORLD RSTANDS, THA
IANSGEMENT SECURITL ENSURE UKRA.
EXAPRESIDENT PUTIN LIED
US.IDO IN. CLEARLY.TO
N ANYTIME SOON ANDNDO OTHER WAY.
ONE WAY TO DO OM
ATA.S THE
EURO Y
UNION,R OF NATO.
NEEDS HA
IN
LOOKING FOR
BECSETEES FOTNAS,ING THE UNITEE
DON'E RUSSIANSAGAI TINTORED NAOI
WHAT THEOOKING FE SECOHE
FOR, BOYERS, AE
ASSUE,